Hey youtubers it’s charlie, the full guardians
of the galaxy trailer just posted so I wanted
to do a review.
We got 15 seconds this morning that included
some of the comic con footage that people
had already seen with the hooked on a feeling
song.
Overall it was great.
Marvel took a big chance on this film by using
all these non-human characters, making the
setting off-world and using essentially B-level
marvel superheroes.
Normally they’d only spend this kind of
money on Robert Downey Jr and the avengers.
So let’s talk about the new footage.
We got a better look at the main characters
we didn’t see in the teaser this morning
including Rocket Raccoon and the Nova Core
with John C Reilly.
I loved that he got to do the lineup scene.
It’s like the usual suspects marvel edition.
It’s just meant to establish them as galactic
a holes who have to learn to be a team.
By themselves they’re all geniuses and the
best at what they do, but their attitude betrays
how awesome they can be when they work together.
And that’s really the cool part that we’ll
get to see in the film.
Them being bad ass together.
The film is supposed to pick up when Quill
is 9 years old, so there will probably be
at least one or two montages of him growing
up and then slowly assembling the team.
That scene with John C Reilly looked like
it came much later in the film.
I was a little bummed we didn’t see ronan
the accusser or some of the other more important
secondary characters like nova and nova prime.
But the first trailer is always about the
core team.
So in another month or two we’ll probably
get some new footage.
My biggest questions right now are mostly
plot related because the trailer did do an
amazing job of showing us that visually the
film will look like classic star wars.
Super grimy and amazing.
We didn’t get to hear Rocket Raccoon or
Groot speak which kind of sucks, but I imagine
they didn’t have to change vin diesel’s
voice much just because he’s already so
gravely.
But I wonder what Bradley cooper is going
to sound like.
Marvel and James Gunn were calling Rocket
Raccoon the heart of the film, so I can’t
wait to see some extended scenes with the
character.
Right now here are the top 5 things I want
to see in the next trailer.
Number 5 - Karen Gillan speaking
Number 4 - Glenn close’s Nova Prime character
Number 3 - Lee Pace as Ronan The Accuser
Number 2 - Gamora beating the crap out of
someone
and number 1 - Rocket Raccoon cracking wise.
But let me know what you thought of the trailer
and what do you want to see in the next one?
If you didn’t see I just posted a big preview
for the movie with character breakdowns.
You can click here to watch it.
And click here for my review of the winter
soldier trailer.
It’s almost here!
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!